welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your captain definition in this video
we're breaking down Picard episode six
our mission is to boldly go where no one
has gone before and give our thoughts on
the new entry as well as what could be
happening in the future we're now past
the halfway point of the season and
things are really starting to take shape
throughout this video we'll be
discussing the ins and outs of the vi
episodes plot it's Easter eggs and what
we thought of it as a whole we will be
engaging with heavy spoilers here so if
you haven't had a chance to catch the
show yet and don't want to know what
happens then I highly suggest that you
turn off now if you've been enjoying our
breakdown so far then please give us a
thumbs up and make sure you subscribe to
the channel to never miss a video on the
series without the way I just want to
give a huge thank you for clicking this
now let's get into our breakdown of
Picard episode 6 ok so just a quick
recap of the series so far after the
death of datas daughter dodge picard
made it his mission to track down a twin
sister Shoji
after he and his allies managed to get
Bruce Mannix they discovered where Shoji
was and set out to the ball cube to find
out what was really going on episode 6
like all of the episodes in Picard opens
with a look at the past this comes in
the form of a nightmare that Shoji is
having and we see her as a child
wandering into a father's lab I loved
how everything in the car door looks
warped and twisted and this is mainly
due to its design and it gives an almost
otherworldly feeling so do you wake up
before she can find out the truth and we
then cut to her and Eric in bed and
shouts whoever did the eyebrow makeup on
him because yeah you missed a spot
don't worry though we're not here a dunk
on the episode and yeah it's another
solid entry in my opinion Shoji doesn't
know if her nightmare is a real memory
or if it's something that she fabricated
and we later learn that it's an implant
now this could be a memory of the real
Sochi and perhaps she stumbled across a
father creating a replicated version of
her or it could just be a manner in
which she discovers that she's not a
real person the fact that dodge isn't
there when we know that there were twins
and did everything together highlights
to me that this may be the real Shoji
but I'll leave that up to you to guess
as for now I'm just exploring all of the
options on the ship dr. Agnes has some
splaining to do and she pretty much gets
away with murder this episode is very
bored coupe centric and even the title
The Impossible Box is referencing its
design there's also a box that takes the
form of a puzzle in the episode but it's
great seeing this box within a box
within a box with a book anyway I
haven't really discussed ball cubes on
the series so far so I thought I'd give
a breakdown and what they basically are
ball cubes are known as some of the most
dangerous weapons ever created and it's
a very formidable craft in the right
hands as the Borg operate with a hive
like mind it has no real identifiable
spaces that we tend to see on ships
though the Romulans have fitted bedrooms
of the ship they don't typically come
with it
but there is mention of cells in the
episode ball cubes can carry up to
130,000 Borg drones and it's pretty much
a flying armada Picard has had run-ins
with the Borg in the past and he was
assimilated himself because of this he
has very little sympathy for them but do
you think that the arc of the show will
change Picard's mind and these will be
painted out in a less malevolent role
this is heavily hinted at in the episode
with picaud seeing them up close and
personal now everything for me in the
season so far has been pointing towards
Shoji being a ball queen whether it's
the opening scene of the series in which
data held five Queen of Hearts or the
fact that Shoji is pretty much the
combination of synthetic and organic it
all seems to line up I'm gonna read a
comment on my last video from Joe Grimes
that I think sums it up best
but obviously leave your thoughts below
Shoji appears to be attuned to the
Borges neural matrix learning things
like languages and cultural practices
seemingly popping into a head they then
go on to point out the other things that
indicate this including the badge and a
jumpsuit that changes color to indicate
the collectives presence when the
Romulan trauma victim freaks out and she
has soon Lee became hyper aware of the
feelings of the ex be around her all
unified with revulsion I remember this
scene standing out when I was doing my
breakdowns and the user says that the
victim was almost seeing her primarily
as the source of their pain
I've left a whole comment on screen if
you want to pause the video and read all
of it but there's a lot of way to the
theory and it would be a great dramatic
arc for me if picaud ended up trying to
save one of his worst enemies
Soji seems to know the ins and outs of
the queen's tech including a spatial
trajector which is found in a cell
Picard discovers Hugh and comes across
an old image of himself when he was
assimilated which triggers him and kicks
off the title sequence
now we later see Hugh in the episode and
he mentions the Queen but says that they
are a Romulan now still though there is
another mention of the Queen and I think
they're just hitting us over the head
with it at this point
they arrive at the beta quadrant which
is a former neutral zone the beta
quadrant exists in the Milky Way and is
home to the Klingon Empire
the Vulcans the Romulans and many more
Rios and Agnes get it on but this is
likely just a play by the latter we know
she was romantically involved with
Maddox and well look what happened to
him the guilt seems to be weighing upon
her though we don't know exactly why she
killed Bruce now there are theories that
one commando met her she showed her the
truth about the synthetics that fuels as
a clashes hate for them there was lip
service paid to the fact early on in the
series that learning the secret of the
Jack bash can break someone's mind and
this could explain why she ended up
going off the deep end it is possible
that she knows that soul-g is the
destroyer that is prophesized to end all
life and thus she wanted to kill Maddox
who had ultimately created her maybe she
learned that everyone is a synthetic and
that were all a mix of robots and
organics ok tinfoil hats away I did read
that though it was on reddit so it's a
yeah don't dislike the video now Rick
solves the puzzle and the crew arrived
at the cube after tricking their way
into portraying the mission is a
diplomatic one after the rejection of a
son Rafi is turned to the bottle and we
realized that when Picard resigned she
pretty much lost absolutely everything
this mission is sort of a redemption for
her too giving her at least a reason for
the thing that destroyed her life so
Giri contacts her mother and she says
that a father is in his lab once more we
see that seulji's mother is an AI by the
fact that she pauses at several points
during the conversation and glitches
towards the end of it now whether she is
a Romulan design or not we don't know
yet
but it is possible that this is why
dodge had a different version of their
mother so G scans all of her items and
discovers that they're all aged 37
months indicating that she was only made
3 years ago everything from a past
is a complete fabrication Picard boards
the Borg cube and gets flashbacks to
when he was a member of the collective
he saved by drones which again shows how
the Borg may be being reinvented in this
series after this Picard and Hugh
finally come face to face now in case
you missed our video on episode 3 Hugh
starred in the next generation and he
was a former Borg drone that Picard and
his crew met in the show he was
critically injured during an episode and
taken back to the enterprise-d where he
was cut off from the collective the
character never knew what it was like to
be like this away from the hive and
through the crew he learned that humans
did not want to be assimilated which
contradicted what he'd been told he was
given his name and developed his own
individuality on the cubies been
mentoring Shoji and he leads Picard to
her on the way showing that the Borg are
victims
narak takes Sodhi to the point a year
only room where you can enter into your
own mind now I kind of get the feeling
that narak is falling for Shoji
genuinely and he does seem to be opening
up to her in this entry he even tells
her his true name and I can see him
becoming an ally whilst his sister
becomes the big bad in the room so de
journeys into her own dreams to discover
that she's basically Pinocchio she
notices two red moons and this is likely
where the nest is that the Romulans have
been after this entire time with that
found in Erik walks out the room and
locks are in there he's clearly torn up
by it but it doesn't exactly go back
Shoji activates and smashes her way out
escaping between the two levels she
finally comes face to face with Picard
and he shows her dodges necklace they
escaped to the Queen's cell and after
using the special trajector they
transport through that ELMO shows up to
buy them some time and he does he does a
bit of lego lassen for the finale we
don't see if he kills the rest of those
on board the ship but hey at least he
gives them the option to live Picard and
so she are now out in the galaxy on a
forest planet and now everyone is after
them Riker is coming back by the looks
of it and it seemed as if Picard will be
pulling from its numerous allies whilst
the Romulans and his crew tried to get
to him again I really enjoyed this
episode and it's hinted out a lot of
things and gave some more evidence of
the theories that I've had so far the
show is doing really really good things
right now and
a lot of people are finally getting on
board with it with just four episodes
left I feel like we're really making
headway and now next week looks like it
will potentially be holding back a lot
more of the answers that were so
desperately seeking that doesn't mean
that I'm not enjoying the right but card
keeps getting better for me and I'm
hyped to see what happens next week with
the character and his new ally obviously
and loved hear your thoughts on this
season so comment below and let me know
make sure you check out our full
breakdown of the series so far if you
missed an episode is that's gonna be
linked at the end if you want to support
the channel from his littlest 99 cents a
month then please click the join button
below you get access to content early
and can also suggest video topics and
breakdowns you wanna come chat to us
after the show either follow us at
definition whitey or click the discord
link in the description below every
month we give away free movies to people
are subscribed to the channel and this
month you can win the nfinity saga box
set and all you have to do is comment on
a video and make sure you serve with
notifications on the more videos you
comment on the more you have a chance of
winning it so make sure you get involved
the winners gonna be chosen at random on
the 15th of March in the cell shipped
out from then - ever gets the prize it's
the best of luck to everyone who takes
part this is the channel for people who
are never missing television so if
that's the kind of thing you like you
need to subscribe to definition thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]